Hey, guess what? A few weeks ago,
I finished the Esperanto skill tree on Duolingo.
As you can see right here from the golden calf,...
Oh! ... I mean owl, sorry.
Hello everyone. Welcome to the LangFocus channel,
and my name is Paul.
Today, I want to talk about Duolingo.
It's an application for learning languages, that now has over 100 million users.
I've been using it for a few months,
and it's really an effective way to learn a language.
For free!
Or, so they say.
Nothing in this world comes for free,
and using Duolingo comes at a price.
Quite a steep price that you need to be aware of.
When using Duolingo, you sometimes
encounter some very strange sentences.
Some of these sentences are complete nonsense
but others seem to be a very clear reference to the dark,
disturbing side of human nature.
Some people say that these sentences are just luck,
or they result from random word combinations,
but I beg to differ.
There are far too many of these bizarre,
strange translations for it to be simple luck.
The truth is, Duo wants to possess your soul!
You don't believe me? Let me prove it to you.
The first thing you may notice is that Duolingo is trying
to blur the lines between human beings and animals.
The bear hands the beer to a cat.
The birds drink beer.
Cats drink milk and beer.
The duck is drinking wine.
Well, by this point, you're probably imagining yourself
sitting back, having a drink with a bunch of animals,
which makes you little more than a simple animal. Doesn't it?
You drink my cat's milk.
Well, that really just is an odd statement, isn't it?
The squirrel is our captain.
The girl follows the bear's example.
So, humans. According to Duolingo,
you are supposed to copy what animals do.
Because you should be an animal, just like them.
I am a snake.
We do not know who is human.
Duolingo wants to convince you that you are the same
as an animal. Rather than a spiritual being.
They want you to revert back to your animal impulses,
and your wild instincts.
They continue this process of spiritual destruction
by killing your self esteem.
You are stupid! Well, thank you Duolingo...
You are useless.
You eat like a pig.
You have no culture.
Hmm, well that's really just a low blow now, isn't it?
Now you have no friends.
You have rings under your eyes.
Yours is small. Well, yeah, it probably is a little small,
but, you didn't have to point that out, thank you.   ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
You are just average.
Sometimes I doubt your intelligence.
Man, I am a loser. You know what, I'm kinda starting
to feel like that after reading all these sentences.
When you have no self-esteem,
you will easily begin to hate others.
What the Duo demons do next is
make you feel contempt for other people.
No one is good.
My parents are ugly.
Here's a nice, little cynical statement.
She loves him for his wealth
Your niece is stupid.
Your parents are strange.
His head is bigger than a football!
Hm... Little judgmental now, aren't we, Duolingo?
I do not like the rich. Hm...
Once Duolingo makes you hate yourself
and hate other people, now you are all alone.
And they are free to shape your reality.
Next, they flood your mind with bizarre and grotesque imagery,
to cut your old connection with reality,
and begin pulling you over to the Dark Side.
The bear gave birth to a duck.
The boy eats 23 beetles. Now that's something
I just don't want to even imagine.
The engineer is in the refrigerator.
Now I'm imagining this engineer in pieces
in the refrigerator, so, this is getting kinda creepy.
I am eating an elephant!
Okay, poaching, eating endangered animals.
Do you import people?
Human trafficking, that sounds like the way to go.
That is not water, it is yellow.
Sorry, I'm eating a rabbit.
The cat lays the mouse into the milk.
What the Hell for?!
The kid eats insects.
And this guy just looks so happy about that.
A tiger is eating my husband.
The wolf eats me.
Do animals have blood? Well yes they do, but,
we don't usually focus on it unless we have to.
Now that you are fully open to manipulation, Duolingo
fills you with a fascination for death and violence.
How does an animal die?
I am going to die.
Why is the kitchen full of blood? Well,
that's probably because there was a double homicide.
I am ready to die. Well, I'm not. So, please,
don't make me repeat this sentence over and over..
You shall bleed!
Defeat the babies!    And exactly,
in what context are we fighting these babies?
She will go to Hell.
I'm starting to think we are all going to Hell.
It is necessary that the husband dies.
He has to die! And look,
she's so happy about it, isn't murder fun?
Why do you have so many wounds on your body?
Well, it could be because I have spent the last hour
killing husbands and wild animals on Duolingo.
Soon, they will shoot. Look how excited this woman is
by that incoming onslaught of firepower!
You can die.
We all commit crimes at times.
Where were you at the time of the murder?
Now Duolingo knows that they're probably going to get
you into some trouble. So they're just preparing you
for that inevitable interrogation.
Once your mind is filled with violence, then you are just
a single step away from committing acts of violence.
While Duo watches and laughs.
The last step is designed to ensnare your soul
permanently because of it's addictive nature.
Duolingo seeks to fill your soul with sexual immorality.
You must be especially careful
when learning these sentences.
May I kiss you? Well this one seems innocent enough,
but, of course, it's a slippery slope.
My boyfriend eats in the bedroom.
The boy pleases the girls.  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Yeah, this is something we really shouldn't
be thinking about, but, ...
you know, it's not that bad,
he's pleasing them, he's making them feel good.
You drink a man's juice. Well, no I don't, but,
I guess there are some people out there who do.
He has a big black sack.
He likes balls. Well, to each his own...
I am not your toy. Yes, I know the feeling,
it's kind of frustrating, isn't it?
I eat your pink strawberry. 0_0
I have zero pants!
Okay these cards are still bad,
they're still obviously the work of the Devil,
but maybe they're not as bad as the others.
I guess we should still be careful though.
The lawyer is being washed by his secretary.
Yeah, I know this one is kinda bad,
but, sounds kinda fun too, you know?
She raises her shirt.
Yeah, sometimes women do that, um,
I shouldn't look when they do but, you know.
She takes my sugar.
She wants to taste my crepes.
You sleep between them? Well, yeah sometimes,
it's fun to sleep with multiple people.
There's nothing dodgy there, just sleeping.
You need to get out of here before my husband arrives.
Well, this situation sounds kinda adventurous or exciting.
Well, so you see that Duolingo comes up with a lot of
*interesting* sentences. Of course, it's good to be careful,
but maybe it's not really such a big deal after all.
Like, you have to have a sense of humor right?
And of course, you enjoy your life
and seek pleasure, shouldn't you?
After all, you only live once and then you DIE.
If God wanted us to be so spiritual,
why did he give us these animal instincts?
You know, Duolingo really is quite fun,
there's something special about it.
I don't quite know what it is, but I have a special feeling
and I don't know where it comes from.
I just know that you should probably try Duolingo,
very soon, and you should probably use it every day,
as much as you can.
You'll learn many things.  ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Right, Duo?
Thanks for watching, everyone.
If you enjoyed this video, then please like or share it,
especially with other fans of Duolingo.
And if you yourself have found some interesting, funny,
or strange sentences, inside Duolingo,
please write those in the comments down below.
And we'll be sure to check them out.
Thank you for watching, have a nice day.